welcome to plate to date today I have  three gentlemen making glances for me I  cannot wait I'm David I'm Ian I'm Andrew  what I'm looking for in a man being  open-minded is a big one somebody that's  open to trying weird things I'm looking  for someone who is a person to come back  to at the end of the day so I made a  pumpkin Supply splints pumpkin spice  cream cheese in there fold that over and  we are gonna finish it off with three  mint leaves  this is one of the tastiest things I've  ever eaten wow amazing okay I need a  response like that you're ready to step  on the glass look at this he's certainly  a planner he also probably tastes his  dishes so he's I did do that mindful of  the things he does I think that's a very  important characteristic for me and a  partner somebody that is attentive and  mindful